[Music]
know everyone and welcome to my talk on
acing and streaming JavaScript are we
doing it wrong of course the answer is
always going to be yes else why am i
standing on stage here and what what
better picture then to show John
McCarthy telling us we are exactly doing
programming wrong so before I get
started I actually want to thank the
organizers very much because of course
this is my first time speaking here but
I've been coming here since 2010 and
without a a conference such as this
things like node nodejs on windows might
not have happened or it might not have
happened as quickly as it did so it's
with this very conference that really
really is amazing stuff to me so what
I'm talking about a sinker or a sinker
or event based program I think of myself
well I thought I had a problem so I know
I'll solve it with callbacks and events
now have now problems too I yeah hmm
crap yeah
concurrency bugs I've been bugging me
since I've started doing JavaScript and
what this talk will not be is that it
will not be a monad tutorial there will
be no mentions of category theory it
doesn't require to you to know much
about functional programming to really
get started to learning new abstractions
for for asynchronous programming so know
they're not like burritos and no they're
not like any other silly metaphor that
you can think of to describe monads so
Who am I I am a software engineer and
self-described open-source
you can find me on the on Twitter and
and github pretty much using the same
same tag I'm fairly unoriginal that way
and I worked for this the small startup
out of the Seattle Washington area I
don't know if you've heard of them but
they're called by Microsoft and I like
to think of myself as putting a little
bit of metal back in Microsoft ad routes
to anything automatically turns it into
metal so I work on a project called the
reactive extensions and I've been
working on this since 2010 the idea
behind the reactive extensions is really
to to to create a nice program
programming language agnostic way of
dealing with asynchronous programming
and yes I'm Matthew popper sake am an RX
pusher now really what I want you to get
through first is that I want some some
quotes that'll help us in our learnings
today the first one is to be conscious
that you are ignorant is a great step
towards knowledge the next one is
ignorant never settles the question and
the third one is the best way to be
acquainted with a subject is to write a
book about it or in my case get up here
and give a talk about it and this was
given by the the prime minister of the
UK back in the 19th century so let's
just face it asynchronous programming as
we know it today is annoying because by
themselves you have every library and
every certain thing doing its own thing
whether it's callbacks and promise
promises doing one thing where it's
yielding a single value versus events
where they're dealing with multiple
values so each concept is covering its
own little piece of the story not the
whole piece so just to kind of give you
an example here I certainly wouldn't
call a promise on a on an event that you
expect from more than one of just as you
wouldn't do you wouldn't
we need a collection to describe a
single value but even more than that how
about if I want to make a web request
and then combine combined that with
getting the key the key press events so
that I can send my data over to that and
then we need to make sure that we're not
overloading the server how do we think
about that when we're just talked about
promises callbacks timers etc how do we
deal with that is there a better way
that we can think about asynchronous and
event based programming well we had a
very forward-thinking president in the
United States who in the early 60s came
to this very city and said ich bin ein
Berliner
but what he also said is we choose to
solve asynchronous per of programming
and do other things not because they are
easy but because they are hard
citation needed daemons wikipedia so
callback hell is very much a real thing
so when you're dealing with callback
hell you've got a nested function after
nested function where you're trying to
accomplish something linearly so for
example here I might want to to play a
movie what that Inc what that entails is
making sure that the players initialized
that I'm authorized to do so and then
when I'm then when I'm done done it
authorizes me with a movie tickets and
what you end up with is a cow's head all
your code code all it looks like is just
the cow's head at that point somewhere
the logic gets lost and it's evil so I
don't know about you but whenever I
write code like that this usually
happens and it's it's not easy to
recover from those from getting burned
like that and just as well event based
programming is just as annoying say for
example we want to create a drag event a
custom kind of event that we we do on a
run
so what we would need for that is we
would need to say whether the mouse is
down or not and have some state as to
where where the mouse is then in the
mouse down we would have to say okay
Mouse is down here so here's where we
started mouse move we go okay
Mouse is down let's do some calculations
and on the mouse up we say everything's
done we're good to go and then we have
to of course not only add the event
listeners but we also have to remove
them as well
and that gets pretty darn annoying and
so when you're dealing with that much
states once again you're juggling and
you just can't hold it especially when
you're true when you're just trying to
do something else add something new to
your program that's what you end up with
so let's talk a little bit about the
asynchronous programming landscape as it
were so we have well the programming
landscape in general we'll have two
accesses one to describe synchronous and
one to describe a synchronous behavior
and one one part to say whether it's a
single value and one to say that it's
multiple so for example when you're
dealing with a value that's what you get
you call a function or you assign it a
value that's a value good an iterable is
a collection so in JavaScript we have
arrays we have maps sets arguments
anything that's iterable here and then
we can apply higher-order operations
such as map filter and for each on them
but what about asynchronous single
values of course we have callbacks but
we also have promises now promises are
very interesting in the fact that now
instead of this callback function what
you have is you have a first-class
object that you can pass around the
people that describes what that value
eventually will be and that's not
something you can necessarily do with a
callback I can't hand you a call back
and say now this or this represents a
value doesn't work that way
and then what I'll put in the fourth
quadrant and final quadrant is
observable now observable as you will
see is asynchronous in its in its very
nature so you can take the same stock
stock data you can filter it you can map
it and you can for each it no code
changed at all in terms of what you're
coding on the clients nothing none
whatsoever
and that's very very intentional about
what we're what we've done with the
observable design so if you know how to
program against collections then you
know how to program against observables
what I like to say a lot of the times is
that your mouse is also a database so
it's a database of coordinates that you
will get eventually when the mouse moves
therefore it should be as queryable as
an iterable sequence is so the thing
that I like about these abstractions is
that they're first class and then what
they means by first class is the fact
that I can pass one of these objects
whether it's an observable or it's or
it's a promise to to a function and I
can also return it from a function and
so what that gives us is it gives us a
lot of flexibility when it comes to to
querying something or for testing for
mocking whatever else it is it's really
nice for for us to do that
now promises I'm sure you've heard a lot
about here already I've seen it
mentioned in a good number of talks
already now promises are great because
they're pretty much in every single
library that's that are out there
nowadays and they have pretty much the
same behavior outside of jQuery I which
you have is you have very uniform
behavior so you can think about them all
pretty much the same handlers done
asynchronously and once it's done it's
done you're good everyone gets the same
answer so we can take the previous thing
that we talked about the the callback
hell and all and distill it down to the
player initialize authorizing the movie
or for handling the login error playing
the movie or saying you're on
authorized boom no more any of these
trying to finish and detecting whether
this state is available or not but there
are some problems I have at least when
that when it comes to promises promises
don't solve everything so for example
cancellation is not a part of the
contract for promises in es6 why well
there in a good number of reasons is
because you want most people to fall
into the happy path and be pretty
productive but it's very much the case
when you deal with a lot of things such
as such as dealing with i/o where
cancellation is a normal part of what
you do well and what about situations
like an autocomplete where you just
don't care about the value that comes
back so in this particular case here am
i how do i cancel that again I don't I
don't not really interested in this
anymore
Aaron so do I create a cancellation
promise and I subclass the regular
promise do I pass in a cancellation
token do i or do I just use a library
like last from Dominic de Nicola any of
those are perfectly valid valid options
now when I talk about reactive
programming so reactive programming is a
very kind of fuzzy definition just like
functional programming is everyone says
well functional programming application
of functions not helpful so what we were
trying to do is trying to figure out
what exactly we could call reactive
programming so the dictionary says
readily responds to a stimulus I'm like
well isn't that just normal programming
what else is interesting about it well
reacting to events is certainly one
thing that that reactive applications do
but they also react to loads so the fact
is that you can spin up more instances
to handle data you can determine whether
you need to drop data and so forth you
can react to failure so if at any point
that you need to to to handle some
errors and
return it from cash you can certainly do
that but to me most most importantly is
reacting to to your user the last thing
you want to do is have your your
javascript page be unresponsive to a
particular user and what I'd like to say
is it is you know the reactive extension
stuff that I've done has played a little
bit of the role but you know there are
there are a lot of there's a lot of hype
obviously around there with Gartner and
so forth in reactive programming but
when I'm talking about reactive
programming here I'm just talking about
observables so why don't we actually
take the the previous example of that
mouse mouse drag and kind of turn it in
inside out and turned it into an
observable solution what would it look
like well if we had this first class
object of the mouse down we can take
that and combine and start to do a
calculation so flat map will basically
it will take a sequence and it will
flatten it into into a single value or a
single stream of values rather then we
can calculate the offset of where we
started
for every Mouse down now we can start to
take the mouse moves by once again using
functional programming things that we
already know with using arrays and the
array extras we can say take the mouse
move which is also another first-class
object map it so we can decide to give
the left on the top so the total
differential between the two okay
pretty good so the problem is we'll be
going on tongue like this and then
forever it'll keep on going because it
never responds to it to the mouse up
well we can fix that by saying take
until Mouse up so Mouse up once again a
first-class object we can say whenever
this fires stop the sequence we're done
and it even holds a little bit more
promise suffice it to say when you're
dealing with promises so what if we want
to take some some input for our as it
were take the inputs value and then
we're going to to call make an
autocomplete scenario here
so what we want to do is we don't want
to overload the server because our
bandwidth is time and money quite
honestly so what do we need to do to fix
that well we have things such as
throttle throttle or debounce as most
people know it where you can type type
type type stop for half a second and
then suddenly it will fire excellent so
if when we're thinking about observables
we're thinking about once again back to
that axis there we have the observable
and we have the observable and we have
the notion of a synchronous or
time-based then we can get the value
make sure it's distinct so it hasn't
changed and then what we can do is we
can call a service which might be a
promise only getting the last one
so the one of the biggest problems with
asynchronous programming is is what is
that you are dealing with with the fact
that you could get out of order
responses and this fixes that so and
then you'd buy that to the UI and you're
good to go
and even more complex things and I'm not
going to even bother explaining all of
this but even more complex things such
as pulling for row updates yeah that's
that's pretty complicated but rx handles
it just fine what we need to know is
everything's a stream good it's a very
zen-like moment you're like yes I got
this this is not to be confused with FRP
so FRP is is a notion of continuous time
behaviors are our objects with a
continuous piece of data time and a
continuous value whereas events are
different events only have values when
they fire and most of those that is not
it is not just any old library that has
map filter and reduce on observables and
so most FRP libraries aren't so what
about generators so I'm sure that a lot
of people have seen what generators can
do and so yield suspends the function
and resumes when you actually get the
value back
and a number of libraries already
support this well the library that I
work on does it as well as well as
kyouko and a number of those things so
once again you can say retry three times
here and you still get the benefit of
observables but yet you get a very
Linear's imperative style CSP yeah I'm
okay on I it's interesting but a lot of
people seem to love core dot async and
they seem to think that it's a good win
like I said I'm not all that amused by
it because it makes air handling very
manual it makes resource management very
manual not a fan a single weight also is
is very worthwhile in terms of
discovering what's new in in JavaScript
so what we have is we have async await
which has has been approved for es7 at
least the first stage so what we can do
is we can now take some some animations
and we can start to await each one as it
comes through that's pretty powerful so
it makes it explicit that we're dealing
with an asynchronous function so we
don't have to deal with this function
star and yield stuff it makes it very
very obvious now let's quickly talk
about stream processing now when you're
in node I don't know how many people
dealt with streams one but let's face it
they're awful the pause didn't data just
started immediately
you can't consume a number of bytes you
did everything just got shoved at you
and pause and resume are just impossible
you know it was basically this
so then we catch streams too which
landed in n09 and then eventually in the
stable of zero 10 and then supported
object mode now and everything was good
then we also got readable writable
classes and so forth duplex and pass
throughs and then streams 33 and a third
whenever they decide to to land in and
12 e0 12
I'm sure that Olaf that'll solve
everything - but cork uncork pretty cool
stuff in terms of being able to to deal
with math data rights but still to me I
it's too complicated so the what wygor
w-what WG streams what they're trying to
do is trying to standardize a lot of
this for the low-level api's for what
what's going into into the browsers so
Dominic who is here he he is working in
that and right now it's currently
focused on low-level IO and it's unicast
in nature meaning only one one person
reads one person writes etc it's
interesting but could we could we take
and generalize what he's trying to do
what we're trying to do here into a more
general kind of thing where we're
talking about like observables and the
answer is yes and the and the the answer
unfortunately is darts dart is doing
those kinds of things where asynchronous
programming they do with futures and
streams automatically so futures great
streams unify IO and events together so
literally your open read and you're out
you're on click same thing you can use
the same API throughout all of them now
reactive streams is a is an effort
that's going on because a lot of people
in the observable world say well you
can't do back pressure can you I mean
cuz come on
you deal with with a lot of people
handling your data we can't possibly we
can't possibly have know how to deal
with this you know a node and others
have it very easy where you have one one
coming in one going out that if you kind
of crimp the hose that's fine
nope no big deal but when you're dealing
with a multicast situation it kind of is
a big deal so with observables we
actually do have notions of back
pressure they could be lossy for example
I could be possible sampling them
throttling them whatever they can be
lossless so I can buffer them possible
buffered so pause and resume or control
so for example here I can take my chatty
observable possible buffer it then pause
and resume and I anything that happened
in between those pause and resumes I
still get and just as while we're
building it into the very core parts so
each subscription will then be able to
say I want to request n number of items
so once again back pressure is something
that we have definitely under our belt
now where do we go from here I think
there's actually a lot of places that we
can go because because of the fact that
async/await all these other things are
kind of pushing the envelope I and
that's a really cool thing but what if
we could go even further
so in es7 ja far from saying who is a
member of the tc39 ECMO script
standardization committee has proposed I
a sync async generators in which we
could take that very same Mouse drag and
put it into the for on kind of syntax so
you could say let Mouse down on element
Mouse downs which is once again that
first class object document that Mouse
moves once again first class object tot
take until document Mouse ups yield the
mouse move good so that to me is very
very interesting and I think there are a
lot of places that we can go with with
these kinds of
approaches so I will be upstairs if
anyone has any questions or if anyone
wants an Rx sticker come find me
I want to thank you very much for your
time
you